so this is another mind trip from
christopher nolan be honest with me john
when you first read this script
did you get it did you understand
everything that's happening
i took before i was to read it and uh i
guess because i
saw after after reading it i guess i was
so delusional that i thought i did get
it so like at least for the first time
i felt really pretty confident that i
understood what was going on
and as the day progressed as it went on
i realized oh i didn't get i
i lost everything i don't i don't you
know so
um you know it took some time to catch
up to christopher nolan and catch up to
the concept of it but once i did
i felt very confident and comfortable
about how to execute his vision
right speaking of executing that vision
i want to talk about the fight
i know some of the footage is probably
reversed but it does seem like
you had to learn choreography fighting
in reverse
is that true that is that how'd that go
that is a wonder a wide net of discovery
i mean it was interesting working with
the stunt team that i did with jackson
and george
uh cotto who's been working with uh
chris for a long time and they've been
in the industry doing what they do best
for a long time and even they were
discovering new moves and and new ways
of
fighting uh so that was exciting to me
and it made me feel
a little better about myself about my
confidence like okay nobody has ever
done these moves
in the history of cinema like nobody's
done this so this was new
you know this was a new frontier it was
great yeah so carefully screwed up
the body but uh man like once she once i
felt comfortable and confident about it
i was ready to roll yeah it was
mind-blowing it just insane okay hear me
for a second
because my dad was a high school teacher
at the school that i went to
and my thing was always don't talk to me
about my dad if you're in this class i
don't want to know i don't want to
like combine those two worlds okay i
love seeing you on screen with kenneth
branagh because obviously
your dad was in much to do with about
nothing which i love that movie
do you do you want to hear those
conversations that people that have
worked with your dad do you have those
conversations you're like no that was
him this is me
like do you want to talk to kenneth
about your dad i feel like kenneth might
have got annoyed with some of my
i was oh really i'm about it man because
i watched that movie
tirelessly i was i was i was it was a
religious uh
experience man i loved that that film
watch it all the time
so i was asking all kinds of stuff about
that movie and he was he was
he was very kind and uh and he would
answer some things but i i might have
gotten i know he might have gotten
annoyed with me because i kept asking
about stuff
i just found his anyway but uh the fact
that it was a trip knowing that uh
he worked with the old man you know so
so so many years ago so it was great to
to prick his brain about that stuff yeah
i'm sure it's a trip for him too
yeah yeah now it wasn't lost to me that
you're the first black lead in a
christopher nolan movie like was that
something that really registered with
you
well uh i mean because it wasn't it
wasn't written in the script
you know first right he and chris know
that it wasn't written in the script
described as
black male 30s that you see a lot of
black males that you see a lot in
scripts
um so i i i didn't think about it i was
thinking about the
what who the character is yeah
absolutely now
obviously christopher nolan has made
this movie he wants this movie to
be the movie that brings people back to
theaters like this the release date's
been changed i think like what like four
times
something like that it's really become
this movie that people are discussing
and some people are
frustrated that they you know they have
to make the decision of whether or not
they're comfortable going back to a
theater at this point how do you feel
about
releasing the movie right now in
theaters well doing these um
you know i was a bit uh it was kind of
it kind of hurt knowing that
it wasn't going to be released on time
but i want you know because of what's
happening but nobody can predict
what is happening uh doing these
interviews today
and uh and seeing these posters
everywhere it makes it seem like they're
it's really going this time and if
that's the case then i i'm so excited
about it i can't wait for people to get
get back to the theater safely and uh
and be able to watch this
yeah and this movie is so complex so how
would you
prepare audiences for this how do they
go into this
what they say in the trailer in the
movie don't try to understand it
feel it it is true it is so true just
enjoy
being in a theater and and looking at
an event that's happening it's an event
film you know it's it's such
wonder and spectacle and location and
and
and uh scale beautiful scenery and
and just i think you'll connect with the
characters you're going to connect with
the world
that uh that christopher world
christopher nolan's bringing you into i
think it's worth it
so just enjoy it and then on the second
and third viewing
try to break it down and deconstruct and
have those conversations if you like
right
well absolutely congratulations on this
movie and i just got to say you had so
much swagger
in this movie like i loved your witty
replies to people the one-liners
were absolutely amazing they were my
favorite part of the movie so
congratulations john
so much i appreciate that thank you for
saying